hi there so
uh before i start i have a bit of a
stutter so
um if that makes it hard to understand
then i apologize
hopefully it'll won't be too bad so
um i sent a tweet out
a few days ago
uh i loved javascript
with statement so much and
i got a reply from uh ciao
pianki i think you say his name i love
the javascript
with steven so much with sarcasm tags
around it
he thought i was being sarcastic
actually he forgot the opening tag so
maybe he was saying everything that i've
ever tweeted is like sarcastic
however i guess from this point on i
can't be sarcastic because he just like
closed the sarcasm tag on me so there we
go anyway
um oh and then i got this one whatever
yeah
all right so by way of introduction i
i work at twitter
um twitter we love javascript
we love the front end we take the time
to understand
everything understand all the parts um
so that we have the widest toolkit at
our just
proposal we don't believe in just
restricting the language
to the so-called safe parts or
you know the bits you should be able and
i think we get a lot of strength from
that
and we do everything in strict mode just
in case you thought we were
not very careful or something like that
so um why am i making this talk why did
i write it there were two
motivations for this talk um the first
one
is kind of represented this quote by
douglas douglas crawford
he says the subset he carved out is
vastly superior to
the language as a whole
now much as i love the good parts and
think it's a great book and i think
every javascript developer
should heed it um
i think the other parts are really great
as well the party leaves out
if you take the time to understand them
they are great and they're really useful
and they add a lot
to the language and it saddens me that
not enough people are actually looking
into them so that was one of the
motivations
the other one is this i see this all the
time and it drives me crazy
it's like stack overflow
you're reading a fairly interesting
thread and inevitably someone comes
along
and says that and it's like you're not
telling me
you're not explaining it you're not
saying
why i shouldn't use it you're just
telling me not to use it
like why are you telling me this because
someone told you
you know we we can't be good developers
unless we take the time to understand it
and we should not
preach things to other people that we
can't explain
or we're not willing to convince others
of
that's very important to me
so why
do we have rules rules well
rules help us to do it right
um that's the theory
but who
makes the rules whose rules are we
actually
following here and i think right
and rules apply to everything not just
the software
they apply to life they even apply to
soup
right as it applies to soup
so let me ask you something
what is an authentic ministroni soup
um does anyone know
well i tell you what we can do do a
search
google images will have the answer let's
key in authentic minnesota soup
and see what we get oh
turns out there is no such thing there
is no authentic minestrone soup
it's whatever you want it to be and
actually the technical answer is
it's a regional soup and different parts
of italy
make the soup in a different way
um but the point is we can't tell other
people how to make
minister honey soup and i guess that was
meant to come next
and the bigger point is correctness is
sub
is subjective there is no one
correctness that we all share
we cannot listen to one person's story
of what correctness is and apply it to
our to our development
um each of us is
unique and individual each of us we all
have our own opinion
on what we consider harmful
um these are all um actual
the copy pasted from actual articles and
you can see
uh everything in javascript has ever
done has been considered harmful by
someone like if considered harmful
primitive types
arguments javascript consistent
and so um you know oh and look
there we are and just to throw it really
throw a spanner in the works somebody
actually wrote an article
vowel considered useful
so clearly harmful is subjective too
otherwise we wouldn't be writing
any code at all
um i really like this quote from
swiss author jermaine destiel i think
i'm saying that right
um rules are only
barriers to prevent children from
falling we should
keep that in mind that's really
important so when you start out when you
learn a language
you know rules are really important they
stop you falling off the edge
stop you doing something really stupid
but you know
we're not children anymore right we're
adults we job we
like most of us in this room probably
consider ourselves fairly good
javascript developers we would want to
code the way an adult codes and
um we once we understand the rules
um we should be able to
break them find out the exceptions find
out when the rules don't apply to what
we're actually
trying to do uh is
thomas here in the audience uh thomas i
apologize for this
um singapore everything runs smoothly
everything's clean everything's nice but
there's a bit of a cost for that
it's the expense of personal freedom not
everyone
has the liberty to do everything they
want to do
and i think java is singapore actually i
yeah thank you
actually uh i i i didn't come up with
this i stole this from andrew
dupont who said it at a great uh jsconf
talk
uh two years ago i think
um so ask yourself how singapore do you
want
javascript to be
um that's pretty important
uh this is a great quote i really love
this quote this is pretty old now this
is from 11 years ago
i think it's still wikipedia policy
and it's one of their great strengths
they have
guidelines they have rules but they're
very quick to point out
if it holds you back if it prevents you
creating the site the page you want to
create
then it can hurt it
again i think we should be adult enough
to do the same thing okay so we talked
about breaking rules
how to break them
let's start with my own favor the
quiz statement
so to be sure um there's a lot to be
careful about
when using the with statement you
shouldn't just use it
indiscriminately uh here are a few
reasons not to use it
um accidental clobbering
and implicit global creation is very
easy to do uh here's a here's an example
looks pretty cool on the face of it okay
we have an object literal
we're using a with to make another
object literal
like statement two so there we go
to update um the dragger that we just
created you wouldn't really get these
two lines next to each other but
one of them on the same slide but look
i accidentally misnamed increment as as
interval an easy mistake to make
and all hell broke loose i've now
created a global chord
interval it's pretty easy to do should
be careful about that
oh the obligatory ironic footnote
is with the s5 strict mode
they protect against implicit global
creation so the biggest
egregious um fault with the withstand
would have actually gone away
with the s5 unfortunately es5 doesn't
support the
post statement it's kind of sad
um to be fair uh the compiler costs
might have been prohibitive because
trying to figure out whether with
statement
whether globals were being uh clubbered
a lot of browser vendors would have
complained that was actually prohibited
expensive so that might be the real
reason there isn't a with statement
in uh es5 shake mode
okay carrying on with reasons not to use
the with statement
uh cost of closure scope resolution so
with
adds an extra scope so as you're going
up the closure chain looking for the
trying to resolve that's an extra that's
an extra
step to go up in practice i think the
way modern browsers work
it's an exaggerated concern i don't
think it slows browsers down
that much
and the cost of lake compilation we need
to
resolve the effective property access
and assignments we can't do that
till one time so it's an extra compiled
compile step
again not sure how much that costs
maybe sometimes it is a significant cost
turning to the positive why is it useful
well you probably know it powers your
developer tools that's if you use chrome
or safari or firebug
here's an example taken from chrome
source code chrome developer tool source
code
and actually this is very slightly old
they've changed this
but it was this particular excerpt was a
very good illustration of what happens
so you may know that the um
pipe kit console has this command line
api
which um makes available extra functions
such as the inspect function
things things things like that which you
can just use on the
console there all within this object
window.inspector command line
api but what if you wanted in the
console
to override those functions uh we want
to the user of the console should be
able to clobber those functions
this is a very neat and instantly very
safe way to do that you have a with
windows statement nested insider with
window inspector command line
so absolute priority will be given to
the global of
jet and so if you redefine it inspect
it'll get to that one first
then it'll get to the inspector command
line api
why is it safe um nothing can ever slip
through the
global object because you're actually
including it there
um another reason it's useful a lot of
people like
block scope so es6 is going to be
introducing support for blocks
scope with statement is a pretty neat
and fairly safe way to replicate
block scope let me show you by
illustration
so you've all seen this one right
this is like a cautionary tale of how
closures don't always work
so because there's only one scope here
the variable i
is being shared through each iteration
which means the alert statement ends up
pointing to node's
length every single alert alerts
nodes length length at the end
the traditional way to solve that is
with a function closure right
you've all seen this i'm sure uh so now
we're introducing a scope inside a scope
so
i is unique each eye is unique within
the function scope that we created then
everything works great
it's a little bit clunky um
it's not very intuitive and people
coming from other
languages don't really think it's a bit
over the top having to do this so you
could have a with statement
and here's the key another key to using
with in a safe way is don't have a
variable wearing ava we don't know
what's in there
pass an explicit hash so you know what's
there pass i
as a hash then you can only
you own it so there's no danger of a
saying
of a sane person trying to set anything
else in this with loop other than i
because it's clear that's all that's
actually there
so nothing will be accidentally
clobbered and it's kind of lightweight i
think compared to the function thing
um actually to be honest it's slightly
slower
but so it depends if performance is a
concern to you
but i think it's a fairly neat
illustration
and oh by the way there is a let
statement coming in es6 but
like we know that's not going to be
there on all browsers for quite a long
time so
this is a kind of standby i guess eval
statement
um everyone's other favorite thing you
you should never do um
why shouldn't you do it well we all know
about code injection loophole
if a user gets or if some third party
gets their hands on the argument the
eval argument they can
invoke any code they want to
um also uh prevents closure optimization
because a lot of modern browsers all
modern browsers i think
um th they they will only persist those
variables on the other scope that
have to be persisted so they'll look
what's referenced in the in the inner
the inner scope with the value you don't
really know what you're going to be
referencing there so it
inhibits optimization um
i'm not sure with chrome and the latest
firefox how much of a problem that is
um but anyway that's something you don't
get
if you have a vowel statement
and again as with the with statement the
cost of lake compilation
so you have to compile at one time
basically
why is it useful most obvious one is
when there's no
json pass so like ie7 for example
um there's no ability to to
to have a native json pass in the
browser these are a couple of um
accepted answers from stack over flow
uh basically saying the same thing to
the effect that
you should never use the vowel it's
really unsafe use
json.org it's much much safer okay
let's have a look at json.org well if
your browser didn't actually
support the about um jsonpass it uses a
vowel
so this is why you should watch stack
overflow because
often accepted answers are just
completely wrong
um why else is it useful it's how your
console works
it's the same as the with statement so
you can try this now
aspin bin or to any webkit console
run this code anything that you evaluate
the eval statement is what actually
calls it this is this is just saying
what is the caller of the function the
eval statement calls they use the eval
statement for everything it's used every
time you run something
here's a quote i really like from john
hey query fame um
it's like the sensible antidote to the
crocodilism
it's like basically he says
here violin with a trivialized misuse
and outright condemned by most
javascript programmers but when used
appropriately they allow for the
creation of some
fantastic pieces of code that wouldn't
be possible other
wise i think that's really cool and
uh i wish more people would pay
attention
to to this kind of thing um
this is the the cousin of the eval
statement
um slightly nicer cousin in most
people's view
although i've heard it said it's only
nicer because it isn't an eval statement
therefore you can say you're not
using a vowel but you actually are
that's not really true
um it's not just an available in
disguise it's much more besides that
in particular it always evaluates code
in the child
of the global scope so it creates a
brand new scope
every time to execute in which is one
down from the global global
scope which means it only has closure
reference to the global scope
and to nothing else and we'll see in a
second
why that's a good thing or can be a good
thing in the right
context let's look at a couple of
cases why it's useful or actually
talking about what i just said
um you know your evaluated code will
always run in the same scope or not the
same scope but an equivalent
scope every time um
now it's pretty bad anyway if a third
party gets
hold of your argument but at least with
function you function only the globals
are exposed they can't get deep down
into the local code because they'll
never be available
in the in the scope chain
and finally there's no closure
optimization concerns because the only
uh variables that in the scope chain are
the global variables which are there the
whole time
they're always persisted so there's no
issues there
uh it's used in jquery's past past json
which is a kind of variation on json.org
version
um it uses the eval it substitutes the
vowel for
a function constructor as we can see
here otherwise
it's pretty much the same and this is
again presumably to restrict access to
local
variables and because at least in theory
less scope chaining means uh
performance in movement
so i just leave that code up in case you
can see it
uh where else is it used underscore js
has a pretty pretty nifty string
interpolation
method um
and it uses our favorite with statement
first what what this interpolation
lets you do is you can
optionally give a context in which you
want this string to be
interpolated to be evaluated in
if you don't give a context it'll just
create an object hash here
so it'll either run it in the given
context or just create an object hash
in the latter case with an object hash
it will then um
use it in a new function constructor so
the default hash
doesn't run in you your local scope it
runs in the new function scope
which makes a lot of sense because since
you clearly stated you don't care what
scope it runs in
okay i'm going to run it in the quickest
and safest possible scope
so i think that's i think that's cool
and that's a good example of where
with and the new function function
constructor work
quite nicely um
together uh running a bit short on time
so i'm going to
speed up a bit now uh equals equals
uh how many people use it
that's pretty good not as good as i
hoped but
uh pretty good why are you not meant to
use it um coerces operands to the same
type
so if you have a string and an and a
number
it'll it'll curse them uh what are they
oh that's
that's it's actually that's the only
reason
so um why is it useful oh because it
coerces operands at the same time
like sometimes you really don't care if
the user is input a string
or a number if it's quote two or two
you don't care does it is it gonna ever
evaluate to
two it's it's useful if you are doing
that you should put a comment though to
to let people know
that's why you're using equals equals
because otherwise it might confuse them
um and then there's this thing undefined
is equal equals to no
which is pretty handy because
javascript has two nothings it has null
and undefined
and some people do if x triple equals
null or x triple equals undefined
but that's a mouthful and is logically
identified
it logically identical to x equals equal
to null
and you see a lot of libraries like
jquery use the x equals equals null
yeah they they use that the whole time
just makes a lot more sense
uh does exactly the same thing
and also if it's obvious why the hell
are you using triple equal
like type of is always a string type of
result of type of can never be anything
other than a string
so type of something equals equals
function well like
yeah you know you might as well do to
do an equals equals similarly length and
index or all
poison number and i actually i mean this
is a matter of style
but i actually prefer equals equals in
the sense because it's more
declarative i'm being very transparent
i'm saying to the reader of my code
i actually know these are are the same
things that's why i'm using
using an equals equals comparator
or rather writer uh
if i put triple equals it suggests i
don't actually know it's the same
type uh personal preference that's how i
like to do it
oh and uh in his number two in our
obligatory uh
ironic footnote series a lot of the
people who avoid equals equals
with impunity they use if something the
whole time
well that's coercion too so it's like
why is one type of coercion okay and the
other
type not and it's not even the same
coercion
so either they've understood the if
coercion but not the equals equals one
not sure why you would want to take the
time to understand one and not the other
or they don't understand if coercion but
because crawford said
it's okay they're just basically going
ahead and using it
and here's an example of why the two
coercion types are not the same
so uh you know
if potato evaluates to true but actually
potato is not equal equals
true so there we go
uh array constructor um so
right you're not supposed to create a
raise this is not how you're supposed to
create a raise right but
what about this this is this is the most
beautiful thing
and you need the array constructor to do
this um
you've probably seen this this is from
prototype.js and it's a way to repeat a
string
x number of times and it basically
creates an empty
array of x plus one times and uses as
your glue as the glue
the string that you that you provided to
it
um i think it's ultra cool and
it makes me really sad that some people
will never use this
or would never want to see this in their
code because they followed a rule that
somebody once said
and they never really took the time to
understand it so
there we go oh wrong direction
so people that broke these rules also
like to break
these rules and i'm running out of time
there's way too many rules so i'm going
to be really really quick
but i just wanted to make it clear these
aren't the only rules so again
andrew dupont two years ago at jskov
gave the best talk about
extending extending native prototypes
just to quickly say sometimes it's
sensible
i think es5 shims are one case where
it's sensitive
sensible has own property on for in
well you know if you created the hash
yourself and you didn't instead
extend it and you didn't extend object
prototype there's no way
you could be bringing anything else into
your to your to your iteration
and i bet you nine times out of ten when
you do a foreign iteration that is
exactly the case
the other thing is what's so bad about
prototypes
sometimes we want the prototype to i've
i've
i've done four in loops where i want uh
prototype objects to leak into my
foreign it
for in iteration too so it's all a
question of what you actually want
in the iteration put all of our
statements at the top well
good advice most of the time but in for
loops it's frankly unintuitive because
you're looking for where it was defined
over the top there's no reason to ever
define it up at the top
in a for loop um don't declare function
after use it this is basically the
hoisting thing like function
declarations do function hoisting
items find it really useful to hide the
implementation details further down the
page where the person looking at my code
might not care what the implementation
is but they'd like to see
where is it used how is the function and
i i find that
actually pretty good uh comma
operator as jes said i basically wrote
the essay on this one uh
i could give you 100 reasons to use it
but i'll just give you one
um if you want to use multiple
expressions where the syntax it only
expects a single one
like the second or third arguments of a
for loop
are really good examples of that and
the one i hate is always past 10 to pass
in
i mean unless you're starting with a
zero or an x there's no reason to have
to pass
10 to a person so
in summary it's okay to break a rule if
you understand why the rule exists in
the first place
you can mitigate or safely ignore in
other words the concerns don't
apply to what you're trying to use it
for
and maybe most importantly it adds
something like
there's a reason to break the rule and
here i might mention semicolons i think
semicolons
um contrary to what you might read
they're pretty easy to understand
why and why and how automatic semicolon
insertion works
i'm fine with people not using them i
personally
don't leave them out because it doesn't
add anything either it's very easy to
put a semicolon
in this case sticking to the convention
doesn't really cost me any anything
leaving out it's not really going to add
anything to the code so
there we go this is a quote from an
author i don't know anything about the
author but i really like the quote
um and i think it really sums up pretty
nicely what i'm trying to say
which is become an expert at the rules
then break them with creativity and
style
and like the um tldr take away from this
if you didn't listen to anything else
just listen to this is
be good and if you can't be good
be careful thank you
so uh we're only a little bit over time
uh there is ten minutes until the next
break
uh or do we have maybe i would i think
this is such a great opportunity to have
this guy
speaking uh to answer questions and i
know there's so many there i mean
personally i i would have questions that
i'd want to ask him about stuff like
this but
um do we have questions uh if you want
to leave uh
not root at all go out and you can you
know have a beverage um
but if we have questions maybe entertain
one or two while we have mirror is that
cool
i see one in the back one second oprah
style
thank you great talk um i
agree with you on a lot of this i think
most of these rules exist for teams
but the team is fairly large and not
everybody is the javascript programmer
don't you think that as well yes i was
going to add a slide about that i did
actually have a slide about that and i
took it out
i think uh teamwork is a good idea to
have
some conventions that the whole team
should follow and i guess all i'm saying
is yeah sure have those conventions
but decide amongst yourselves what those
conventions should be
don't listen to what other people say
understand the rules as a team
understand how you want to employ them
anyone else alright cool thank you so
much